thousands of women are expected to
protests across the country tomorrow in
the latest women's March the first one
on the day after president Trump was
inaugurated in 2017 drew millions of
demonstrators it's thought to be the
largest single day protest in US history
but this year's event has been marked by
division and accusations of
anti-semitism Alex Wagner spoke with one
of the movements key leaders Alex good
morning good morning Nora the Maine
women's March will once again be held in
Washington with about 300 sister marches
also planned nationwide Linda Sarsour a
co-founder of the organization told us
she is enthusiastic and excited about
this weekend despite the controversies
we will not allow heat anti-semitism
anti black racism xenophobia
Islamophobia in our movement two years
after the first women's March Linda
Sarsour has plenty of reasons to
celebrate sexual predators have been
exposed by me - and a record number of
women now walk the halls of Congress The
Satanic Jews but on the eve of the March
Saur Saur is instead addressing
controversy surrounding Nation of Islam
leader Louis Farrakhan and his
anti-semitic rhetoric call me an
anti-semite stop oh man do turn my
Minister Farrakhan is not on the board
of the women's March we does not have
any influence on the women's march in
2017 Tameka Mallory the women's March
co-president described Farrakhan as the
greatest of all time this week she said
she was praising farah khan's work in
poor black communities and not his hate
speech it's not my language it's not the
way that I speak it is not how I
organized I think that we have grown and
evolved as a woman's March leadership
many members of the women's March
have never really had to address issues
of anti-semitism so you're saying there
is a place in your organization in this
movement for Jewish women is there also
a place for people who support some of
the lessons of dr. Farrakhan everybody
is in our movement so yes it's difficult
it's messy to create a big tent but we
have tried to do that and it's not gonna
be easy
unity is not uniformity do you feel like
the Jewish community has been receptive
to that line of argument absolutely
we've been having dialog for the past
nine months with rabbis across America
with Jewish leaders across America but
some local women's March chapters have
disbanded in protest and Vanessa ruble a
Jewish co-founder of the group says she
was forced out the last few weeks have
been challenging ones for your
organization major national
organizations including Emily's list may
roll the DNC they have put some distance
between themselves and your organization
what's at the root of that what's at the
center of this controversy is really
what has been at the center of every
single attempt at intersectional
feminist movements how do you bring
women from all backgrounds lack women
white women asian-american trans women
Muslim and refugee women so we're really
going through growing pains where hope
people continue to believe in the work
that we do because the common enemy of
white supremacy and this administration
is a far larger threat to all of us in
the past the White House has said the
president condemns racism and bigotry
organizers are open about attendance
dropping since that historic 2017 March
which they anticipated three years in
but expected poor weather and lingering
controversy may add to that they have a
mission statement it seems like a lot of
these organizations if you have a clear
mission statement about what you believe
in yeah that helps work out some of they
wrote me releasing they say this weekend
a set of policy proposals but part of
the 2017 March was intersectionality
we're gonna bring in a host of different
issues everyone is welcome we're gonna
create a big tent but that has led I
think in part to some of these and on
traverse it's interesting that you're
seeing some high profile Democratic
politicians distance themselves now from
the organization as well and from the
beyond Farrakhan Thank You Alex very
much thank you